looking at some photos is where we're
going right now number three in
Manhattan 620 red-eared slider turtles
were rescued last month after being
smuggled from China 13 Buddhist monks
visited them and chanted a 20-minute
blessing that happened it is amazing
Humane Society International is looking
to place them in permanent sanctuaries
if you have one get in touch species can
grow to more than a foot in length and
live a hundred years number two back to
China somebody built a new company
office what does it look like Tom I can
see it right away it's a hurry Spock
other solid bridge there's so much it's
a real building yeah the real building
is so much money in the world it's
amazing that office will be the
headquarters for netdragon websoft it
builds mobile apps building costs 97
million dollars to construct yet they
even had a seek permission from the
owners of the Star Trek copyright
trademark to build it there right our
number one photo in London a lock of
mozart's hair will be auctioned tomorrow
at Sotheby's it is estimated to sell for
fifteen to eighteen thousand dollars so
we had to ask about this this morning
air court presented this photo and we
said why is it that we even have this
evidently was common in eighteenth and
nineteenth centuries to take a composers
hair as a keepsake we do that with all
our guests right way we do that yes i
have a yes you will get a sensing
something you will get one of my locks
in an envelope later very venture yes
you're okay boats are sure that all of
this so the sale also conclude some of
Beethoven's here worth less than
Mozart's so you guys can fight that one
out on your own